what I want to do in this video is to
give you the gist of what the Roth the
Roth IRA is all about it just to get a
nice idea of why it's called the Roth
IRA it's named after William Roth the
late senator from Delaware he helped I
guess you could say Shepherd this
legislation in 1997 when it was first
passed so they named the IRA after him
William
William Roth from Delaware so that's
where the word comes from so it's a
special type of individual retirement
account so why did they go to the
trouble of creating a new one so let's
think about what a traditional IRA does
and then I'll talk about why a Roth IRA
could be interesting or it's a little
bit different or what could be
beneficial and then we'll actually see
it in an example so the first question
is what happens when you put money into
a traditional or Roth IRA in the
traditional IRA video you saw that is
tax deferred tax deferred that if you
were to put $5,000 in your traditional
IRA you are not taxed on that money in
the Roth IRA it is not deferred it is
not deferred so you would actually pay
taxes on that $5,000
so immediately you're saying hey gee you
know this doesn't seem like that great
of a thing why would I ever use it I
have to pay taxes on the money I put in
and this is the interesting thing in
both situations or as long as your
investments stay in the either
traditional or Roth accounts earnings
earnings earnings are not taxed are not
taxed while in account this is true for
both of them this is true for both of
them but you're still going to say hey
Sal the traditional still looks a lot
better I had to pay taxes on the Roth
right from the get-go I didn't have to
pay it on the traditional and then they
can both grow and I can buy and sell my
stocks or I invest in mutual funds or
whatever I do inside of them I don't pay
taxes the traditional still looks better
now the interesting thing is what
happens when you would draw the money so
there's a lot of special circumstances
on when a withdrawal is qualified or not
I'm not going to know the details I
really just want to give you the essence
of why the Roth is interesting so let's
say you're over fifty nine and a half
years old fifty nine and a half years
old and in the Roth your money's been
there for more than five years it's been
seasoned I'm not gonna go into all the
particulars so the traditional IRA when
you withdraw so let's say we're older
older then older than fifty nine and a
half for both and then we do a
withdrawal with drawl in the traditional
IRA you have to pay taxes you pay taxes
you're taxed ordinary income tax
ordinary income tax income tax while in
the Roth IRA no taxes not taxed not
taxed and we saw in the traditional IRA
video that this is tends to be pretty
good when you're older than fifty nine
and a half you might be retired you
might be in a lower tax bracket you're
going to pay lower taxes on it and it's
been deferred for however many years
your IRA has been in existence now this
is especially interesting because over
here you paid tax just on the original
amount that you put in and then you
allow that original amount to grow over
many many many many years and then all
of a sudden you're not taxed at all so
that all of a sudden becomes a little
bit interesting this seems like a pretty
good thing to have and we're gonna
actually play with the numbers to see
how they work out now the other
interesting thing about the Roth is if
you early withdrawal early withdrawal
early withdrawal for a traditional IRA
you pay ten percent ten percent penalty
on the withdrawal plus you get taxed
plus taxes on the Roth IRA if you're
just taking the original amount you put
in and I'll do this with a numerical
example if you're just taking out your
principal amount
no taxes or penalty on the principle no
taxes or penalty penalty on principle on
principle I've spelled that badly print
principal and you will only have to pay
even if it's a non-qualified withdrawal
and there's all these special
circumstances what's qualified and and
I'm not going to go into the details you
will only have to pay the 10% penalty
10% penalty and taxes on earnings and
taxes on earnings and one of the main
reasons why I'm not going all the
details is one it would make the video a
little confusing but also the government
is constantly changing the details so I
want this I want you to be able to watch
this videos many years in the future and
not to be dated so I don't want to go
into all of the different things that
the government is changing from year to
year but let's just do a very basic
example just to get the sense of things
so let's look at a traditional IRA
traditional and then we have a Roth let
me write IRA just to be clear that we're
talking about an IRA in both
circumstances so let's say my original
income amount let's say I made more than
$5,000 I'll just use $5,000 as my
example and also make another note Roth
IRA is subject to more limitations in
terms of your total overall income and
that's also changing so I don't want to
be specific on the numbers you could
look that up but there are ways that you
can transfer traditional IRAs into Roth
IRA so that's kind of a little bit of a
loophole on being able to get around
some of those restrictions but anyway I
won't go into the details just yet but
just remember Roth IRA there are some
more limitations on whether or not you
can put things into it but if you're
tricky you might be able to get around
them so let's say you have $5,000 and
just so you know the limits on IRAs they
apply to Roth or traditional or any
combination of the two so if you you're
starting with $5,000 so in the
traditional IRA you have
zero taxes initially in your Roth IRA
initially let's say you have a thirty
two percent tax bracket just like in the
previous video thirty two percent tax
bracket then you'll pay thirty two
percent on fifteen I'm sorry on five
thousand dollars thirty two percent on
five thousand dollars that's point three
two times five thousand dollars that's
sixteen hundred dollars so you're going
to pay you're going to pay sixteen
hundred dollars in taxes so your amount
in the account so in your account your
principal principal in your traditional
IRA maybe I should write it out here
starting with that five thousand dollars
your principal principal is going to be
five thousand dollars here and it's
going to only be yet to pay yet to take
sixteen hundred out for taxes so it's
only going to be thirty thirty 3,400
3,400 right there now let's say in
either situation you were to take that
invested in some stocks and then five
years later five years later you were to
it doubles so let's say it's some future
point it doubles and you sell those
stocks so that becomes ten thousand
dollars in your account there and then
this you invested in stocks and it
doubles this becomes seventy eight
hundred dollars seventy eight hundred
dollars in your account right here so
this is ten years I think I said five
years into the future I'm just picking
that into into the future and let's say
we're still not fifty nine and a half
years old just yet now we could just
continue to leave each either of these
amounts in our account until we're 59
and a half but let's say we have some
type of need we need a
we need to give a loan to our
brother-in-law or something so we really
want to have access to this money so
let's look at the situation where we
withdraw if we were to withdraw if we
were to withdraw well let's think of a
couple of situations if we were to
withdraw $3,400 $3,400 let's say that's
exactly what my brother-in-law needs
just right now so if we were to withdraw
$3,400 in the traditional IRA sense in
the traditional IRA case so - so we take
out $3,400 we're going to have to do two
things first we're going to have to pay
taxes on it so we're going to have to
pay 32% of that assuming we're still in
the same tax bracket so $3,400 times
0.32 is equal to we're going to have to
pay a thousand eighty-eight dollars in
taxes so we're going to have to pay one
thousand eighty eight in taxes and we're
also going to have to pay a penalty on
this entire amount on the $3,400 so
we're also going to have to pay ten
percent penalty three hundred and forty
dollar penalty so we're going to be left
with after paying all of this this is
let me get the calculator out let's see
the calculator right there we're going
to be left with 3400 - 1088 - three
hundred and forty dollars is equal to
nineteen seventy two dollars so we're
left with 19 1972 dollars now in the
Roth IRA when you needed that money all
of a sudden you decided to withdraw it
early and we're only taking out thirty
four hundred dollars so we're taking
them out the amount that was our
original principle in the Roth IRA we
get the $3,400 because that was our
original amount and we pay no taxes so
we act or penalties so at any point in
time on the Roth IRA you can always take
your principal out and the other types
of our IRAs not only will you have to
pay taxes on it you're also going to
have to pay a penalty on top of that so
the Roth IRA one of the very positive
things is it gives you a lot of
flexibility now let's say you won't need
it to withdraw I don't know let's say
you need to withdraw $4,000 with draw
this is another scenario for $1000 at
this same point in time within the
traditional IRA scenario once again
you're gonna have to pay 32% of that in
taxes so you're gonna have to pay four
thousand times thirty-two percent in
taxes and you're also going to have to
pay plus four hundred dollar penalty
penalty in the Roth IRA case you pay
nothing you get your thirty four the
original principle you put in that was
your original amount $3,400 and I'm in
all of this I'm assuming that we're not
59 and a half years old just yet so in
the Roth situation you get the $3,400
free and clear tax and penalty free but
the other six hundred dollars the other
six hundred dollars you're going to have
to pay thirty-two percent taxes or
whatever your tax bracket is and then
you're also going to have to pay $60 a
ten percent penalty on just the earnings
portion remember 3400 was your principal
then if you want to take four thousand
out the six hundred extra that's stuff
that you earned that stuff that was
grown from the principal so you're gonna
have to pay plus another $60 penalty but
it's still a much better situation if
you do the math than this one here so in
general if you think if you're not sure
whether you're going to need that money
before you retire the Roth gives you a
lot more flexibility now let's go all
the way to retirement let's go all the
way to retirement let's say we invest
let's say we didn't ever withdrew any
money we invest it in another stock and
so we go ten years later so we never
would throw any money we never withdrew
any money we're just going to look at
the retirement situation and we go to
our stock and we sell it our new stock
we get twenty thousand they're here we
get fifteen thousand six hundred dollars
and of course in both of these
situations
great that we're able to buy and sell
stocks inside of these retirement
accounts and not pay taxes if these
weren't sitting in retirement comps
every time we bought and sold the stocks
we would have to pay capital gains tax
and you saw that in the previous video
now now that we are over let's say we're
60 years old we're 60 years old we can
now withdraw our money from either
situation there are some other vil
stipulations your money has to be
seasoned has to be sitting there for
five years and all that I won't go into
the details but let's see what happens
when we withdraw the money let's say we
have a 25% tax bracket now 25% tax
bracket so we're retiree we're earning a
little bit less money we are in a lower
tax bracket in this situation we're
going to pay when we would draw from a
traditional IRA we are going to pay 25%
in taxes which is $5,000 in taxes and we
are going to be left with $15,000 for
ourselves to spend in our retirement
years in the Roth IRA situation once
we're over 60 years old our tax bracket
doesn't matter we just get the money we
just get the money $15,600 free and
clear so if you think about it in either
situation when we withdrew early the
Roth IRA was much more forgiving
especially if we would draw less than
the amount that we originally put in
$3,400 the Roth IRA does not tax us or
give us penalties it only does that on
any money that we earned any money in
excess of the $3,400 the traditional IRA
taxes us and penalizes us on everything
on everything and then even when we go
into the future remember in the
traditional IRA and the traditional IRA
we didn't pay any taxes to begin with
but we had to pay taxes to end with so
when we paid taxes in the end we're
paying taxes not just on what we put in
initially we're also paying taxes on all
of our cumulative earnings right we
originally put in 5,000 now we're paying
taxes on 20,000 so we're going to only
end up with $15,000 while in the Roth
IRA we don't pay taxes on anything
for I guess in return for being willing
to pay our taxes front-loaded to pay
them in the beginning we would never
have to pay taxes on that money or on
any of the earnings that that money
makes now I fix the numbers here to make
them close depending on your tax bracket
before and after or how much growth you
actually see in your earnings one maybe
better than the other but these are
important considerations and so I just
want to let you know the the pros and
cons the Roth IRA tends to be better in
terms of giving you this flexibility and
never not worrying to pay taxes at the
end and there's one other thing and this
is you know depending on how you view
life it might be a minor thing in the
traditional IRA when you're 70 and a
half they force withdrawal force
withdrawal and then of course you have
to start paying taxes on things in a
Roth IRA there's no age limit no age
limit so that's another consideration
you might want to take into